[Musique]
et bonjour à tous bonjour à toutes
bienvenue dans ce live j'espère que vous
avez eu le temps de prendre un petit
café après le repas ce qui doit être à
peu près 2h de l'aprê par chez vous et
puis que vous êtes prêt à démarrer cette
petite discussion aujourd'hui donc si
vous avez des questions aujourd'hui
hésitez pas à discuter parce qu'on est
un peu là pour ça
c'est un sujet qui fait pas mal
polémique en ce moment et bon j'avais
envie de l'aborder étant moi-même
concerné
et et puis à ce sujet du coup je vais je
vais remercier ceux qui on déjà essayé
de l'aborder dans la sphère zthétique
parce que c'est vrai que c'est bah
beaucoup de zéthéticiens étant de sexe
masculin souvent ils ont pas trop
conscience de ce problème là et c'est
vrai que qu'on le veille ou non c'est un
sujet qui qui est souvent plus réservé
aux femmes qu'aux hommes et et du coup
bah il y a pas grand monde qui en parle
donc voilà je me suis dit que j'allais
apporter ma petite pierre à l'édifice
pour une fois et puis euh et puis ça ça
servira peut-être à quelqu'un qui sait
c'est un peu le but voilà alors ce que
je vous propose de faire aujourd'hui
c'est de commencer par euh ce petit
article là qui était sur Santé Magazine
euh ça nous mettra un peu dans le bain
pour la discussion je pense et puis et
puis partir de là et voir un peu ce que
c'est qu'une routine beauté parce que
j'imagine qu'il y a des gens qui qui
peut-être NT pas idée de ce que c'est
qu'une fameuse routine beauté n'est-ce
pas donc j'ai j'ai préparé quelques
exemples et puis on va on va voir un
petit peu ce que c'est que tout ça voilà
voilà donc euh c'est un article publié
sur Santé Magazine qui a été publié le
23 octobre
2022 euh et qui du coup est Cigné par
euh le professeur anque barbau qui est
dermatologue et allergologue
de merc le docteur sing couteau maître
de conférence à la Faculté de Pharmacie
de Nant docteur Richard grosse qui est
un médecin toxicologue cette foislà et
chez Aromazone qui est un site en ligne
si vous ne connaissez pas pour aller
jeter un œil si vous voulez c'est
notamment ce qui un site qui vous permet
de faire votre cosmétique maison si vous
êtes chez vous et que vous avez envie de
de vous lancer dans la fabrication de
cosmétique maison et de faire votre
propre tambouille c'est un un site qui
qui sert à ça et donc évidemment vu les
récentes actualités
sur les par les cosmétiques et un peu
toutes les dérives qu'on peut avec tout
ça bah ce genre d'article est finalement
d'utilité publique et et permet d'y voir
un petit peu plus clair dans ce que dans
ce que on nous propose en supermarché
voire même en pharmacie parfois voilà
donc on va juste lire un petit peu tout
ça regarder ce qu'il y a je vais
peut-être essayer de d'expliquer deux
trois trucs en plus j'ai quelques
exemples en haut et j'ai un deuxième
article après à vous à vous montrer
aussi sur quelques dérives et quelques
quelques pratiques euh que que vous
pouvez voir certaines
fois qu'on vous peut vous proposer pour
des des soins soi-disant anti-âge euh
qui peuvent peut-être être un peu plus
délétaire que ce que vous croyez on va
regarder un peu tout ça ensemble et puis
bah si vous avez des questions
évidemment euh n'hésitez pas les
produits de beauté ne doivent pas nuir à
la santé pourtant les enquêtes récentes
ont dénoncé la présence d'ingrédients
irritants allergisants et perturbateurs
endocriniens près de 400 produits
cosmétiques crème vernis démaquillant
déodorants lingettes ouais les vernis à
ongles c'est particulièrement toxique ce
genre de truc euh contenant un ou
plusieurs ingrédients indésirables ont
été recensés par l'UFC Que Choisir la
liste de ces cosmétiques est disponible
sur le site de l'association de
consommateurs et révèle que certains
produits pour bébés ne sont pas épargnés
donc ce qui est un peu ce qui est un peu
embêtant quand même vous en conviendrez
euh voilà et donc après ce qu'ils vont
faire c'est qu'ils vont détailler
certains produits euh qu'il vaut mieux
ne pas avoir dans nos crèmes ou dans nos
autres produits pour la peau en général
donc en l'occurrence ici il parle des
conservateurs conservateurs qui comme
dans la nourriture sont des trucs qui
sont censés euh empêcher le
développement de micro-organismes euh de
bactéries et autres euh dans les
produits cosmétiques et donc euh il y en
a plusieurs qui peuvent être un petit
peu dangereux voilà donc euh il commence
par la mit donc la m alors le M c'est
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas pour James
Bond c'est l'abréation de mthyliso
tiazon tiazo linon autant pour moi donc
qui est un conservateur qui est
allergisant et donc là il y a le
professeur anic barbau qui nous explique
que cette allergie à la mit explose nous
vooir un cas par semaine dans notre
service ce qui est beaucoup oui
effectivement l'allergie est
handicapante car la MIT est partout dans
les geles-vaisselles des peintures à
l'eau il faut l'exclure des cosmétiques
elle vient d'être interdite dans les les
produits non rincés mais reste toléré
dans les produits rincés donc comme les
shampoing et les gel Douch le
phennoxyéthanol et cetera toxique pour
le foie et le sang présent dans de
nombreux produits cosmétiques aussi et
les risques d'encumuler de plusieurs et
de dépasser les doses conseillées sont
réelles ça c'est un autre problème aussi
c'est-à-dire que généralement on se met
pas quand on a une routine beauté une
routine beauté c'est quoi c'est utiliser
plusieurs
produits cosmétique le matin et ou le
soir et du coup quand vous utilisez
plusieurs produits de beauté qui ont
possiblement à chaque fois des
conservateurs comme ces trucs là en fait
vous allez pas seulement avoir le
produit de beauté qui a le conservateur
vous allez avoir genre CIN ou six
produits de beauté avec ces avec ces
conservateurs là et avec ces problèmes
qui du coup vont se cumuler en fait et
ça va faire que vous allez avoir plein
de bah plus de soucis que quelqu'un qui
n'utiliserit qu'une Seine crème par
exemple donc évidemment dans une crème
c'est limité donc là par exemple
celui-là est limité dans les produits
pour adultes à 1 %. le problème c'est
que si vous cumulez plusieurs produits
bah vous allez largement au-dessus des 1
% vous allez avoir beaucoup plus de
risque pour votre santé par exemple donc
ça ça c'est c'est un petit souci aussi
des routines beauté c'est que vous allez
cumuler des produits qui sont pas
forcément tip top des fois tout seul ça
peut passer mais dès que vous les
cumulez avec autre chose ça passera un
petit peu moins bien euh les problèmes
des parabenes ça avait fait scandale il
y a pas si longtemps avec des histoires
de de conservateur de Paraben d' il y a
plein de produits il a marqué maintenant
100 paraben à cause de ça parce qu'il y
en a qui sont qui sont dangereux
notamment ici le propyle parabè ou le
bythyle parabè dit à chaîne longue il y
a des parabèes qui sont pas dangereux
comme le méthyle paraben ou l'éthyle
parabè qui sont dit à chaînne courte
parce qu'ils réagissent pas de la même
manière euh et donc ceuxl vous pouvez
les garder mais c'est ce qu'il dit ici
c'est certains parabèes à chaînne longue
sont à éviter euh ils sont encore
suspectés d'être des perturbateurs
endocriniens euh donc ça c'est c'est
c'est pas tip top pour votre corps par
exemple à savoir que ça se retrouve
aussi dans l'alimentation ce genre de
choses donc c'est encore une fois si
vous les cumulez ben c'est c'est pas top
les conservateur acceptable donc là il
parle de l'éthyle parabè du mthyle
paraben donc à chaîne courte ça ça passe
et les conservateurs portant la
certification écossère naturel ou de
synthèse et la cosmétique stérile qui du
tout du coup n'utilise pas de
conservateur voilà le parfums qui peut
aussi être allergisant des fois donc ça
c'est c'est pas tip top non plus voilà
généralement moi j'utilise des produits
sans parfum pour éviter ce genre de
problème dans les gels Douch et les
shampoing on n'est pas épargné non plus
parce que il y a toujours des histoires
de sulfate qui peuvent être un peu
dangereux pour la peau surtout s'ils se
sont pas bien rincés euh donc ici le
sodium l'uril sulfate par exemple c'est
ce qui en fait c'est ce qui va faire
mousser quand vous avez beaucoup de
mousse sur vos cheveux avec le le gel
douche par exemple ou avec le le
shampoing ben vous allez avoir beaucoup
de de trucs du style sodium loelsfate
qui sont
détensioactifs donc qui vont permettre
au produits de se mixer avec l'eau mais
qui vont du coup être un petit peu
agressifs aussi pour la peau qui peuvent
provoquer des rougeurs des démanaisons
ce genre de truc donc on essaie de de
limiter ce genre de chos euh c'est pas
parce qu'un produit ne mousse pas qu'il
n'est pas efficace hein fa chercher un
autre shampoing et évidemment les fameux
perturbateurs endocriniens qu'on trouve
quand même à foison en pas mal de
produits de beauté ce qui est assez
embêtant parce que ça va agir sur votre
système hormonal et du coup vous allez
avoir des problèmes alors c'est plus des
problèmes à long terme vous allez pas
avoir des problèmes là tout de suite
maintenant mais vous allez avoir des
problèmes un peu plus tard donc voilà
les perturbateurs endocriniens à éviter
au maximum évidemment donc là c'est ce
qu' disent ici le problème est qu'aucun
signneocinique rapide ne vient signaler
qu'un ingrédient est un perturbateur
endocrinien le résultat sera visible
dans 30 ans et ça c'est un peu
embetttant parce que c'est des choses
qui se retrouvent dans vos produits de
beauté habituelle mais aussi dans les
crèmes solaires donc là il vous en donne
quelques exemples par exemple évidemment
des problèmes aussi avec les produit de
coloration pour les cheveux parce que ça
c'est particulièrement allergisant j'ai
de cas de pas mal de femmes que je
connais qui ont essayé les colorations
pour cheveux et qui se sont retrouvés
avec de l'eczéma des rougeurs des
démangeaisons enfin bref plein de
problèmes c'était clairement une grosse
allergie voilà à savoir que les
colorations pour cheveux c'est pas non
plus le
mieux à éviter si vous le
pouvez et puis bon on n'oublie pas que
les cheveux blancs c'est pas c'est pas
sale c'est pas une honte c'est pas un
problème c'est normal hein ça arrive à
tout le monde donc c'est pas forcément
obligatoire de les couvrir avec une
coloration des trucs comme l'ammoniaque
par exemple qui se retrouve dans les
colorations pour cheveux c'est moyen
j'avoue que je m'en mettrai pas sur la
tronche personnellement on va éviter et
évidemment la grande question est-ce
qu'un produit bio est moins dangereux
alors bioou naturel n'oubliez pas qu'il
y a des produits naturels qui sont très
dangereux aussi he le cianur c'est
complètement naturel ça n'empêche que
j'en mettrai pas dans mon café le matin
que on ne on ne confond pas les deux
voilà la cosmétique bio ne conviendra
pas à certaines peaux réactives car
souvent on retrouve des allergènes dans
la liste des ingrédients donc si on a la
peau sensible restz vigilante vis-à-vis
des allergènes notamment les huiles
essentielles potentiellement présentes
dans les produits les huiles
essentielles qui sont parfois un peu
dangereuse aussi donc à à éviter au
maximum sur votre peau et donc après
vous avez toute une liste de trucs à
éviter dans vos cosmétique au maximum
donc il y a plein de trucs ici alors
tous les noms sont un peu barbares bon
après c'est un article qui a été rédigé
avec des des médecins avec des
professeurs avec des machins donc
évidemment ils vont vous sortir du gros
terme technique et c'est normal euh si
vous voulez voir un petit peu plus clair
il y a des des sites et notamment des
applications smartphone comme celui de
l'UFC Que Choisir alors qui vont pouvoir
vous vous dire quel produit est OK ou
non ils ont même une application
portable et qui vont pouvoir vous vous
dire ok est-ce que ça c'est c'est OK ou
ils vont ils vont vous faire des tests
sur les différents trucs et ils vont
vous dire est-ce que ce ce ce shampoing
est ok est-ce que il est pas dangereux
pour ma santé ou quoi donc si si jamais
vous avez un doute ça peut être pas mal
donc ça c'était juste pour la base pour
se mettre dans le bain on va continuer
avec les routines beauté en elles-même
alors donc on va rentrer dans le dans le
superbe monde des influenceuses beauté
ça va être formidable
euh juste pour vous expliquer vite fait
une routine be donc ça peut se faire le
matin ou le soir voir les deux dans la
même journée c'est pas trop un problème
ça va être une suite de produits de
beauté que vous allez utiliser les uns
après les autres dans le but d'avoir la
peau la plus parfaite possible
évidemment de poser votre maquillage
enfin bref de faire tout ça et donc
chacun il va de son petit produit
miracle de de la manière dont il don il
fait ses phases dans sa routine bouté
vous allez voir il y a plein plein plein
d'étapes surtout qu'il y en a qui en
rajoute des fois il y a des trucs un
petit peu bizarres on va regarder ça
ensemble et je vous propose de regarder
alors celle-là est-ce qu'on va commencer
alors elle commence vraiment avec sa
routine beauté par ici est-ce que je
vous mettre des sous-titres peut-être ça
pourrait être bien parce que je crois
qu'elle est en anglais celle-là et du
coup elle explique donc qu'elle va faire
sa routine beauté après avoir fait ses
cheveux le matin ok donc là elle
explique juste qu'elle fait le maximum
pour sa peau pour qu'elle puisse porter
le moins de de maquillage
possible voilà dans la vie de tous les
jours parce que du coup comme ça moins
il y a besoin de maquillage mieux c'est
évidemment et donc elle fait plein
d'étapes pour se soigner sa peau avant
ça et donc c'est super important donc là
ce qui va se passer dans ce genre de
truc c'est que souvent les influenceuses
beauté vont vous présenter euh des des
produits alors des fois c'est pas les
leurs comme elle par exemple c'est pas
ses produit à elle euh je vais vous
présenter après des il y a il y a
notamment des routines de de star de
cinéma ou de personnalités comme ça qui
en fait ont développé leurs propres
produits de beauté leurs propres marque
donc évidemment elles vont faire la
promo de leurs produit dedans c'est
logique euh mais là celle-là c'est pas
c'est pas ses produits à elle c'est pas
sa promo pour elle c'est juste qu'elle
fait au jour le jour vous allez voir il
y a plein plein de produits donc elle
commence avec un tonur donc c'est un
truc pour qui est censé réveiller la
peau soi-disant euh donc voilà donc tu
t'appliques ça sur le visage pour
commencer mais alors ça c'est assez
marrant aussi c'est que en gros
euh quand vous vous maquillez après il y
a beaucoup de filles qui vont mettre du
fond de teint alors le fond de teint
c'est quoi le fond de teint c'est un
truc qui est hyper couvrant généralement
et d'ailleurs plus c'est couvrant plus
c'est marqué sur dans la bouteille
pouvoir super
couvrant ultra ultra couvrant ou je ne
sais quoi et en fait du coup plus tu
couvres ta peau avec ce genre de truc et
plus tu tu l'empêches de respirer en
quelque sorte plus tu vas mettre des
trucs dans les portes de ta peau qui
vont plus tard développer des boutons
voilà donc là ce qu'elle explique et ce
qui est assez drôle c'est que du coup
elle dit alors moi j'essaie quand même
de pas trop mettre de fond de teint
parce que j'ai remarqué que quel que
soit le fond de teint que j'utilisais
bah ça finissait toujours par me donner
des
boutons ouais c'est plus ou moins ce qui
va arriver si tu utilises trop de fond
de teint tu vas finir par avoir beaucoup
de boutons ouais carrément juste un
petit truc aussi euh la peau pas besoin
de respirer si vous lu mettez 15 couches
de truc dessus qui l'empêche de respirer
bah évidemment vous allez vous choper de
l'acné c'est logique hein euh voilà donc
c'est assez drôle c'est bien qu'elle
s'en qu'elle s'en rend
compte alors le sérum donc elle elle
nous dit qu'elle a dit commencer par
appliquer d'abord un tonneur pour
nettoyer réveiller
rendre la peau plus fraîche whatever
elle a appliqué ensuite un sérum alors
un sérum c'est quoi on va prendre plein
de mots dans la prendre plein de mots
aujourd'hui le sérum c'est quoi le sérum
c'est en gros soi-disant des actifs
ultra concentré donc vous en mettez
seulement quelques gouttes sur le visage
et ce sérum c'est censé avoir être le le
soin le plus important dans votre
journée parce que c'est ce qui va vous
donner le plus d'actif pour rajunir
votre peau rendre plus jolie et du coup
ce sérum ça se vend en toute petite
bouteille à prix d'or vraiment on se
demande d'ailleurs si c'est pas du 24
carats et c'est c'est un truc qu'on met
donc une ou deux gouttes sur le visage
et puis on l'étale et puis on espère que
ça passe bien donc là retenez bien elle
a déjà mis deux produits on est
parti voilà donc elle va vaporiser un
petit peu d'eau pour sur son visage pour
l'instant parce qu'elle a décidé qu'elle
rachèterait pas le sérum
ah et là elle a dit voà et donc là c'est
l'acide hyaluronique ordinary hyaluronic
acid elle a oublié une lettre
normalement il y a un L ici en gros ça
c'est un sérum du coup qu'elle utilise
là avec la vitamine B5 alors l'acide
hyaluronique c'est quoi l'acide
hyaluronique c'est ZE actif qui a été
utilisé en cosmétique ça fait déjà 10 15
peut-être 20 ans c'est utilisé en
cosmétique mais bien dans toutes les
pubs vous les voyez la crème à l'acide
hyaluronique le sérum à l'acide
hyaluronique rajunissant raffermissant
whatever euh alors on va regarder un
petit peu ce que c'est que l'acide
hyaluronique hein bon on on va rester
très basique on va sur Wikipédia alors
l'acide hyaluronique c'est ce truc là et
l'acide hyaluronique en fait ça a
plusieurs utilisations c'est déjà
quelque chose qui est naturellement
présent dans le corps voilà donc il est
il disent largement rép parmi les tissus
conjonctifs épithéliau et nerveux chez
les animaux donc chez nous et notamment
dans l'humeur vitrée le niquy synovial
donc dans les dans les yeux notamment et
il est très utilisé dans divers
dispositifs médicaux médicamenteux et
cosmétiqu présenté dans ce dernier cas
comme anti statique humectant hydratant
conditionneur cutané anti-âge et cetera
en gros c'est la molécule miracle
évidemment dans la vie tout n'est pas
aussi simple et vous allez voir qu'il y
a quelques petits soucis avec celle-là
et d'ailleurs petit petit bonus sur
cette molécule l'acide hyaluronique
contribue aussi de façon significative à
la prolifération et à la migration des
cellules et donc l'acide hyaluronique
est aussi impliqué dans la progression
de certains cancers voilà c'est
merveilleux on l'aime euh donc l'acide
hyaluronique structure de l'acide
hyaluronique donc là c'est en 3D x N
donc on est sur une une molécule qui est
quand même très très grosse he on est
sur de la grosse molécule on est pas sur
un petit truc euh voilà a été développé
approuvé pour des usages en chirurgie
ophtalmique donc c'est une molécule qui
fait partie de base euh de l'œil voilà
application esthétique donc entre les
rides depuis le début des années 2000
l'acide hyaluronique est utilisé en
médecine esthétique comme produit
injectable de comblement de ride alors
injectable hein souvenez-vous bien
injectable là on n pas sur la base de
crème on est sur un truc un peu comme du
Botox qu'on va s'injeter s'injecter sous
la peau euh donc plein de produits à
base d'acide
hyaluronique et donc il tend à
supplanter les injections de collagène
car l'acide hyaluronique a plusieurs
avantages donc il a une bonne tolérance
biologique pas de cas d'allergie une
adaptibilité importante et oui c'est un
hydratant l'acide hyaluronique donc ça
aide à hydrater la peau aussi ce qui est
pas si mal euh donc ça permet de de
corriger le volume du visage on fait des
injections comme le Botox euh voilà euh
ça sert à plein de trucs ça fait faut
faut l'injecter correctement évidemment
mais ça sert à ça si vous le souhaitez
on corrige les cernes on corrige les
plis d'amertume l'augmentation du volume
des des lèvres et cetera les trucs que
vous avez envie d'avoir un peu plus de
volume voilà vous pouvez faire des
injections voilà un traitement fréquent
l'injection de toxine botulique donc le
Botox pour bloquer le mécanisme basal
l'injection d'acide hyaluronique et
alors proposé après ou avant ce
traitement pour venir plus ou moins
lisser la surface cutanée en apportant
du volume sous le pied de laaride à
traiter cet acide aussi a un effet dit
hydratant à faible dose 1 % suffit dans
une crème et la communication
publicitaire des laboratoires de
cosmétiques ont entretenu un effet
psychologique associé à des effets
prétendiments quasi magiques et
spectaculaires de cette molécule active
très utilisée dans les matériaux dit de
comblement voilà vous avez évidemment
des contes indications aux injections
d'acide hyaluronique mais en gros ce Tru
c'est la molécule magique par excellence
vous pouvez faire des injections avec et
puis bah soit- disant dans les crèmes ça
fonctionne sauf que vous imaginez bien
qu'une molécule de cette taille-là que
vous mettez dans une crème il y a de il
y a fort peu de chance qu'elle passe la
barrière de la peau et qu'ell viennent
effectivement se loger dans le derme
pour venir combler vos rides euh non ça
ça marche pas comme ça donc ça ça va
juste marcher en surface et puis ça fera
pas grand-chose si vous l'utilisez en
crème mais bon faites gaffe quand même
hein on est d'accord que l'acide
hyaluronique si vous en avez trop ça
peut être impliqué dans la dans la
progression des cancers aussi donc on
évite quand même voilà donc on est sur
une molécule assez intéressante mine de
rien mais qui ne fonctionne pas en crème
de toute façon faut faut bien se rendre
compte que la plupart des comment dire
toutes les choses qui agissent au niveau
du derme donc c'est-à-dire pas
l'épiderme donc vous avez l'épiderme au
dessus vous avez le derme en dessous
tous les trucs qui agissent au niveau du
derme ce sont des trucs qui sont
considérés comme des médicament parce
que si quelque chose agit réellement au
niveau du derme ça veut dire qu'il est
régulé par l'Agence du médicament et
s'il n'agit pas il n'a pas besoin d'être
régulé par cette agence du médicament
donc il peut être vendu n'importe
comment donc les choses qui sont vendues
sans avis médical ça veut dire que ce
sont des choses qui n'agissent pas au
niveau du derme qui ne rentreront pas
dans la peau ça veut dire que toutes les
crèmes qu'on vous vend au supermarché ou
qu'on vous vend même en pharmacie mais
où il y a pas besoin de prescription pas
d'ordonnance bah c'est pas des trucs qui
fonctionnent en fait ça va peut-être
peut-être vous humidifier un peu la peau
et faire en sorte qu'elle soit un peu
plus on peu rafraîchi ce jour-là mais ça
va pas durer au-delà de 24 he ça ça aura
aucun effet au-delà de ça
et faut faut bien comprendre on en
parlera après il y a deux trois actifs
qui effectivement ont un effet
sur la peau via des crèmes et on en
parlera après si vous voulez mais Cuxa
comme tous les médicaments ils ont aussi
des effets
secondaires c'est pas tout rose non
plusin on est du coup on est sur un
médicament qui est délivré par
ordonnance par un médecin en
l'occurrence un
dermatologue voilà ça laacid
hyaluronique en crème ça marche pas ça
va ça va juste vous rendre la peau un
petit peu plus souple pour la journée VO
ça ça va faire un petit peu
d'humidification sur la peau c'est sympa
ça la rend un peu plus souple voilà mais
au-delà de la journée en
question a plus
d'effet donc on est on est beaucoup sur
ce genre de de produit en fait en
cosmétique alors on en était où est-ce
qu'on continuerait pas notre petite
vidéo du coup on dit plus magique mais
quantique mais oui mais oui bonjour Kyle
bah c'est ça c'est exactement ça c'est
pas magique c'est quantique bonjour je
prends de la cosmétique en antique donc
on repart alors elle on est déjà à son
3ème produit hein on est sur l'acide
hyaluronique qui est donc c'est ce que
je disais he le sérum ça s'applique
parce que vous comprenez c'est tellement
c'est tellement plein d'actifs qui vont
effectivement avoir un effet hein voilà
que on peut pas en mettre beaucoup et
puis de toute façon ça coûte tellement
cher ce genre de
truc
voilà on se tartine bien ah
quelque chose d'intéressant là par
contre elle dit qu'elle va prendre la
crème solaire et là on est pas mal quand
même parce que effectivement la crème
solaire bah c'est bien l'un des seuls
truc antiâge que vous pouvez vous mettre
sur le visage parce que là pour le coup
ça va ça va effectivement fonctionner
alors la crème solaire c'est reconnu en
préventif ça fera rien une fois que vous
avez les les les taches de soleil les
rides ou quoi que ce soit mais en
préventif effectivement ça va stopper
les UV et ça va stopper les problèmes
alors moi étant en Afrique alors je va
ici après j'ai pas vraiment envie de
vous donner une marque parce que c'est
pas c'est pas vraiment le but de la
vidéo mais en gros moi étant vivant en
Afrique c'est le produit que j'utilise
tous les jours et c'est bien le seul en
fait euh parce qu'effectivement euh il y
a des moments où on en a vraiment besoin
quand on est très soumis aux UV et qu'on
n' pas vraiment envie d'avoir des
problèmes de cancer de la peau derrière
c'est euh nécessaire j'ai envie de dire
parce que là les problèmes sont c'est
c'est vraiment pas top le cancer de la
peau j'ai pas trop envie de faire
connaissance avec ça donc euh voilà
crème solaire donc là oui pour une fois
euh on a un produit efficace une crème
solaire à savoir cependant que toutes
les crèmes solaires ne se Val pas euh
souvenez-vous on va reprendre la petite
application mobile je sais pas si ça se
voit là hop voilà et puis bah vous
rentrez le Code Bar ou euh le le nom de
votre produit dedans et puis vous
vérifiez si effectivement il est bon ou
pas donc ça c'est encore euh ça c'est
l'application quel produit euh de l'UFC
Que Choisir qui est mise à jour
régulièrement avec les nouvelles les
nouvelles données scientifique sur les
les produits les actifs les machins les
trucs que vous avez dans vos crèmes dans
vos shampoing dans vos parfums tout ce
que vous voulez et du coup ça va vous
donner un rating don ça va vous donner
un petit profil
ici de de de votre crème de votre crème
solaire ou n'importe là par exemple
celui-là il est toutvert parce que bah
tout va bien il est OK pour les femmes
enceintes il est OK pour les bébés pour
les tout petits de 0 à 3 ans et cetera
donc c'est pas mal du tout ça vous donne
la liste de tous les composants de votre
truc aussi au cas où vous voudriez
regarder par vous-même ce qu'il y a
dedans et vérifier si effectivement
c'est pas dangereux et euh et VO c'est
une application très pratique comme ça
vous évitez les problème voilà donc si
vous choisissez une crème solaire il y
en a certaines qui sont un peu
dangereuses on l'a vu tout à l'heure
dans les dans ce petit article là il y a
certaines crèmes solaires qui sont pas
top mais voilà à vous de à vous de
chercher un peu et de regarder celle qui
vous convient aussi faut regarder mais
la crème solaire c'est encore le seul
actif pour l'instant dans tout ce que je
viens de voir qui a un effet plus ou
moins ok sur sur la peau effectivement
voilà voilà voilà donc une crème solaire
c'est bien ça c'est c'est c'est un bon
début
[Musique]
ouais un produit sur un produit
recommandé sur TikTok mais c'est trop
bien ça dises-moi c'est génial et alors
celui-là bon quand même la
recommandation TikTok c'est trop bien
celui-là c'est euh advance sil
96 power essence alors ça c'est un un
sérum un truc à base de bave d'escargot
parce que parce que la bave d'escargot
pourquoi pas comme ingrédient actif je
mais oui mais oui j'ai dit oui
évidemment on a vu c'était quand cétait
il y a déjà une dizaine dernière on
avait vu débarquer des produits avec de
la bave d'escargot dedans et ça euh
benah j'avais pas compris sur le coup je
voyais pas trop l'intérêt mais
visiblement ça marche encore parce que
là là ça ça a été publié il y a 4 mois
il y a encore des gens qui utilisent le
truc à la pas d'escargot pour pour s'en
mettre sur le visage c'est pourquoi pas
donc là on est sur le 3è ou le 4e
produit je sais plus elle elle a repité
de l'eau entre-temps je sais pas trop
pourquoi mais ça avait peut-être un peu
chaud mais en tout cas donc voilà et
puis surtout c'est un produit TikTok qui
est très bien noté vous noterez quand
même la référence quoi
[Musique]
nickel j'adore c'est merveilleux
c'est ça aussi c'est pas mal c'est c'est
marrant le nombre de choses qui te
disent que c'est pas un produit
comédogène mais qui euh bouge quand même
les portes de ta peau bah oui euh à
partir du moment où tu t'appliques un
truc sur le visage effectivement ça va
finir par boucher les portes de ta peau
surtout plus si tu en mets 15 couches
parce que là tu sais pas combien de
couches tu es en train de mettre sur ton
visage mais il y en a un paquet quand
même hein
euh puis après il y a le maquillage
parce que là c'est le début seulement
mais faut faut voir qu'il y a le
maquillage après aussi voilà on est
juste au début
[Musique]
là c'est mignon mais oui effecement
c'est bien elle se rend compte quand
même que au bout d'un moment les les
produits que tu t'appliques sur le
visage ça finit par par faire des
comédons bah
ouiun moment oui c'est logique c'est
logique et donc là elle continue avec
une une crème alors c'est advance sil 92
all in one j'arrive pas trop à lire mais
bon en gros c'est une crème encore à la
bave d'escargot parce que celle d'avant
ne suffisait pas donc on en rajoute une
voilà ça a l'air vachement bien
aussi voilà donc c'est juste la crème
advance all InOne cream alors all InOne
tu sais pas trop pourquoi mais en tout
cas il y a de la BFF d'escargot dedans
peut-être possiblement a ça peut ça peut
être la publicité mensongère j'en sais
rien mais en tout cas voilà donc ça te
propose une crème à la BFF d'escargot en
plus de celle que tu viens déjà de
mettre avant qui était juste un
moisturizer donc juste un truc pour pour
avoir un petit peu plus de la peau un
peu plus souple voilà pour hydrater un
peu mieux ta peau du coup tu rajoutes
une crème encore
[Musique]
par-dessus
ok ça c'est un autre truc important
aussi c'est à force de se mettre des
produits sur le visage en fait on a vous
avez dans ces produits des conservateurs
qui vous permettent d'éviter qu'il a
trop de développement de bactéries de
champignons de machin truc comme ça
mais à force de mettre les gros doigts
dedans et de les étaler après sur le
visage bah vous allez finir par mettre
dans votre tube ou dans votre peau de
crème des trucs étrangers qui vont venir
possiblement se multiplier dans votre
crème surtout si vos conservateurs ne
font plus effet au bout d'un moment ou
bien si vous avez acheté votre crème et
qu'en fait elle était déjà sur l'étagère
depuis un moment donc le conservateur
est plus très actif enfin bref donc
voilà ça
euh si vous vous appliquez des des
crèmes des des des tas de choses comme
ça sur le visage veillez toujours à
avoir une bonne hygiène pour éviter de
vous appliquer des trucs qui sont pleins
de bactéries parce que les bactéries on
peut se multiplier dans le peau pendant
ce temps-là parce que vous avez pas
nettoyer vos mains avant de faire ça
enfin bref donc veuillez quand même
avoir une bonne hygiène euh si vous
faites ça c'est important donc là elle
elle le dit et ça c'est bien euh il faut
effectivement être le plus hygiénique
possible quand on fait ça pour éviter
bah les boutons encore une
fois voilà donc la crème solaire en
[Musique]
plus génial
oui parce que du coup c'est pas fini
donc elle a fait ses cheveux
entre-temps
[Musique]
voilà donc là on va commencer avec le
maquillage lui-même alors là on est sur
un glow Super G in star glow voilà donc
en gros on est sur un gel brillant qui
va vous illuminer un peu le visage al là
on est pas sur du fond de teint vraiment
c'est un truc qui est un peu moins
couvrant normalement qui devrait un peu
moins remplir vos pores enfin on est
quand même sur une Xè couche qu'on se
met encore sur le visage donc voilà voir
ce que vous voulez faire c'est déjà tout
vu
h
voilà h autre crème supplémentaire c'est
parti oh mon dieu la moitié de la
routine est déjà finie oui B écoute ça
fait déjà combien de produits que tu
t'appliques sur le
[Musique]
visage
alors là c'est très marrant aussi si
vous venez de vous appliquer un truc qui
va unifier le
teint sur la tronche donc ça ressemble à
un fond teint même si c'est pas
exactement un fond de teint c'est un peu
Mo moins d'p heureusement mais en gros
vous venez de expliquer un truc pour
bien unifier tout le temps et puis ben
comme vous avez plus vraiment de relief
sur le visage vous allez rajouter du
relief en remettant de la couleur sur le
visage du coup derrière donc là on
rajoute de la couleur à l'aide d'un
stick stick de couleur un peu brune un
peu bronze voilà pour refire les
pommettes et et pour faire comme si on
était un peu
bronzé
hop voilà donc on met
[Musique]
ça parle beaucoup
voilà donc ensuite on utilise du blush
pour mettre sur les P sur les pommettes
et encore elle en fait pas trop au
niveau du du contouring et tout donc
c'est
bien donc le
blush donc le blush ok très bien ah un
concealer alors ça c'est le l'antierne
qui du coup vous permettre d'en mettre
juste en dessous des yeux il y en a qui
mettent surc sur la paupière sur les
petits boutons si vous en avez et cetera
donc ça vient en plus du fond de teint
c'est vachement bien donc allez une
couche en plus c'est
parti voilà donc là on en met en
dessous voilà donc les
sourcils dit que ça c'est la routine la
plus simple voilà donc gardez bien ça en
tête quand même
le mascara voilà parce que pourquoi pas
et le rouge à lèvres donc là finalement
on est sur quelque chose qui est pas
trop trop
long parce que c'est vrai que ça aurait
pu être beaucoup plus
long et donc après on part sur ce qu'on
appelle un fixateur qui du coup vous
permet de fixer un peu tout ça et
d'éviter que ça partte en 2 he après que
vous l'ayez appliqué sur votre visage et
donc là et je pense qu'on a à peu près
fini il me semble les sourcils ouais
ouais non c'est fini donc je sais pas
combien de produits elle a mis en tout
mais il y en a quand même un paquet et
donc vous imaginez que là il y avit une
dizaine de produits à peu près euh ça
c'est la routine simple vous imaginer ce
qui va se passer quand on va vouloir
faire un maquillage un peu plus complexe
donc là tout de suite on va on va encore
rajouter du produit du produit du
produit est-ce que c'est bien utile tout
ça
euh moi je trouve pas voilà mais bon
chacun son truc donc là on était sur un
exemple voilà qui disait simple et et
minimal pour le maquillage de tous les
jours pourquoi pas alors il y en a plein
comme ça j'en ai sélectionné de
TR en gros elle ça va être pareil et
donc elle elle va commencer avec jeis
regarder un peu vite fait je crois
qu'elle commence
[Musique]
là
voilà donc on va commencer avec un sérum
et avec un autre sérum en tout qu'elle
mélange ensemble pour bien faire voilà
donc on est déjà sur deux produits avec
celle-là ça l'air vachement bien
oui mais je je vois bien que du coup
tuas voilà donc là elle explique elle a
l'air elle aime beaucoup ses produits
parce que bah ça lui donne un air un peu
plus bronzé alors effectivement l'air un
peu plus bronzé avec ça parce que c'est
sûr que ça pour doit peut-être pas voir
souvent le soleil et du coup elle dit
que en ce moment elle a pas mal de
boutons donc c'est embêtant quand même
oui ouii à force de mettre tous ces
trucs là tu risques d'avoir pas mal de
boutons ça
risque d'accord donc là elle dit ce sont
des produits qui sont de drugstore donc
c'est un truc que tu peux vraiment
récupérer un peu n'importe où et qui
sont vraiment pas chers qui sont très
faciles à trouver ça encore c'est un
truc si vous voulez vraiment vous
maquiller si si vous si c'est le genre
de chose qui vous plaît bah nésitez pas
mais mais n'achetez pas les produits les
plus bas de gamme c'est généralement
ceux dans lequel on va mettre les
ingrédients les moins bons pour votre
santé donc essayez quand même de trouver
la bonne qualité renseignez-vous sur le
contenu sur ce que vous appliquez sur
votre visage quand même c'est ben moi je
trouve que c'est important parce que
c'est quelque chose que vous allez
mettre souvent tous les jours pour les
gens qui se maquillent tous les
jours vous imaginez si vous mettez un
truc de toxique sur le visage quand même
alors c'est marrant parce que d'un côté
on choisit son alimentation pour que
elle soit la plus saine possible pour
essayer de mettre les bons
macronutriments les machins les trucs
essayer d'équilibrer un peu tout ça et
de l'autre vous allez vous appliquer sur
le visage toute une somme de produits
non finalement vous ne connaissez même
pas la composition je je trouve ça très
illogique faites gaffe quand même à ce
que vous vous mettez sur sur le visage
surtout que c'est une zone quand même
assez assez sensible et du coup si vous
voulez la préserver mettez pas n'importe
quoi
dessus donc là on est sur
du
on est sur deux deux fond de teint du
coup qu'elle va mixer pour arriver à la
bonne couleur celle qu'elle souhaite
voilà voilà et donc là du coup en fait
elle essaie de de remettre les des
reliefs en quelque sorte sur son visage
V qu'elle a tout enlevé avant ouis c'est
c'est un peu comme si vous faisiez de la
peinture et que vous essayez de de
mettre en lumière les reliefs et de
remettre des ombres et trucs comme ça
voilà alors le concealer après du coup
c'est encore l'anticerne donc elle va
mettre autour des yeux et cetera donc il
y en a quand même pas
mal on est vraiment parti sur de la
peinture là
vraiment ensuite on va de nouveau réuss
partir sur du contour avec des nouveaux
des nouveaux produits pour
hop c'est pas mal en version point en
fait je trouve que c'est avec un petit
point ça fait mignon c'est un peu
dalmatien je sais pas mais elle remet un
peu de d'ombre sur son truc voilà quand
même ça l'air vachement mieux comme
ça elle va en mettre un deuxième
voilà donc là ça va être pour ton pour
le blush là ensuite elle rajoute ce truc
je sais pas trop ce que c'est un élixir
concentré donc c'est un élixir concentré
de de lumière ou je ne sais quoi il y a
vraiment des des noms qui sont
intéressants quand même dans ce genre de
truc et et on rajoute un autre produit
encore par-dessus voilà ça ça
manquer d'accord donc là elle s'affine
un petit peu le nez en mettant des
ombres sur les côté voilà et sur les
yeux aussi pour le rendre un peu plus
profond ça r un peu plus joli
voilà et donc par-dessus tout ça vous
mettez de la poudre de la poudre
pourquoi parce que vous venez de vous
appliquer une couche complète de fond de
teint de tas de truc on l'impression que
vous avez pas tout ça à la truelle et
vous rajoutez par-dessus de la poudre
pour que ça aille faire un peu plus
veloué en quelque sorte un peu plus
naturel je sais pas si vous vous rendez
compte de la quantité de produits qu'il
y a déjà sur cette pauvre peau qui va
qui va se retrouver avec tout ça dessus
pendant toute la journée euh enfin c'est
c'est quand même tu faire ça tous les
matins derrière my easy sum là elle dit
c'est my easy sum makeup routine donc
c'est euh ma
routine makeup euh facile pour l'été
genre elle fait ça tous les jours
pendant
l'été c'est je sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte aussi du temps que ça
prend de faire ce genre de chos et on a
peut-être pas forcément tous du temps à
consacrer à ça et là on en est juste au
début parce qu'après il y a encore il y
a quoi encore il y a les yeux plein
d'autres trucs après qu'Al met dessus
enfin bref les sourcils évidemment à
faire
voilà il y a tellement de de de produits
encore après qui sont utilisés donc
c'est c'est assez incroyable alors il
faut savoir que en moyenne euh la
plupart des femmes utilise entre 6 et 7
produits le matin même si elle se
maquille pas forcément en moyenne en
Europe la plupart des femmes utilisent
entre 6 et se produits euh le matin pour
euh pour leur peau pour pour s'en
occuper 6 et 7 produit ça fait quand
même pas mal hein mine de rien bon ça
c'était une routine en plus mais on
avait aussi plein d'autres trucs alors
bon il y a toutes les stars ici qui vont
vous présenter alors ça c'était hy ro
Bieber je sais pas ça doit être celle
qui est mariée à Justin Bieber j'imagine
j'en sais rien en tout cas elle vous
présente sa routine beauté pareil et là
elle va vous faire un peu la la réclame
pour ses propres produits de beauté à
elle parce que bah faut bien vivre
voyons ma bonne dame qui fonctionne ou
qui fonctionne pas au final on s'en
fiche le but c'est de les vendre donc
elle va servir des géries pour sa propre
marque là ça va être pareil pour
celle-là voilà que vous connaissez
certainement et qui va du coup vous
expliquer aussi quels sont ses secrets
de beauté
euh secret de beauté au final ça l'a pas
empêché de de vieillir vous noterit tout
de même elle est particulièrement partie
sur la réclame de sa propre marque euh
si vous regardez la vidéo vous aur
peut-être regarder un petit bout
d'ailleurs voilà donc elle explique que
c'est sa sa routine beauté avec tous les
produits qu' qu'elle
adore
alors elle se met elle se fait un
smoothie le matin avec du du lait
d'amande et des beurre
d'amande et de la poudre de protéine
parce que c'est quand même vachement
important après tout pourquoi pas faites
le petit déj comme vous le souhaitez pas
de souci ah bah pour une fois c'est pas
bête ça effectivement
votre je sais pas si effectivement
wellness ça pourrait se comme ça mais
mais en gros votre bien-être général et
votre beautés sont lié bah oui si vous
êtes pas en bonne forme vous allez pas
avoir une bonne tête c'est un peu lié là
pour le coup c'est vrai the dry brush
ok pour les
cheveux mais oui bien sûr
ok donc en gros elle utilise une une
brosse à poil pas trop trop mou non plus
parce qu'elle dit qu'il faut quand même
qu'il a un peu de résistance et elle
s'amuse à se brosser le le le corps à
partir des orteils jusque jusqu'en haut
et toujours en direction du cœur
pourquoi en direction du cœur en tout
cas euh voilà donc on va se se brosser
avec une brosse un peu rêche pour pour
améliorer la circulation
sanguine pourquoi pas dire pourquoi pas
par contre euh à noter euh ça dit tout
ce qui est alors là ça s'apparente un
petit peu à une une sorte de une
exfoliation en quelque sorte même si
c'est peut-être un peu plus doux qu'une
exfoliation une exfoliation pour vous la
faire courte en gros c'est vous avez un
produit dans lequel il y a des petites
billes des petites graines des petits
trucs un peu rugueux que vous allez vous
passer sur la peau et qui va vous
permettre de virer les petites impuretés
les cellules mortes les trucs comme ça
euh voilà alors il y en a beaucoup qui
conseillent de faire une exfoliation une
fois par semaines une fois toutes les de
semaines en fonction de la partie du
corps et cetera moi je vous le dis tout
de suite n'en faites pas pourquoi parce
que
l'exfoliation notamment si vous avez la
peau sensible ça va
juste vous retirer la petite couche
protectrice que vous avez réussi à avoir
au-dessus de votre peau qui va être
constituée bon certes de quelques
cellules mortes enfin aussi de cellules
un peu plus anciennes qui vont être là
pour protéger la l'épiderme qui est tout
jeune que vous avez encore en dessous
qui est juste là en train de se
différencier et cetera et et ça va aussi
enlever la couche de sébum que vous avez
au-dessus de la peau qui est là
naturellement pour protéger votre peau
des agression donc si vous retirez tout
ça bah vous retirez toute la protection
de la peau et vous avez des problèmes de
photosensibilité derrière et de tas de
trucs comme ça qui vont aussi qui vont
qui vont arriver donc ne faites pas ce
genre de chos vous allez juste agresser
votre peau parce que c'est vrai que faut
imaginer que faire un truc comme ça ça
s'apparente un peu à passer votre peau
au papier de verre voilà donc on estvite
ne faites pas surtout sur le visage
encore si vous voulez faire ça sous les
pieds parce que vous avez de la corne
vousvez pourquoi pas allez-y mais sur le
visage ou sur la peau des bras qui est
un peu douce
machin non non non faites pas ça donc
non non ça c'est pas c'est pas une bonne
idée d'accord donc tu veux pas vivre
sans ça pour la prochaine partie le GO
glow instant glow ah bah parce que du
coup après tuêtre passé donc la brosse
rèche sur tout le corps tu rajoutes en
plus sur le visage un ExF
supplémentaire le GO glow microderme
donc exfoliant c'est la même chose
c'està-dire que c'est un truc qui va
contenir des microbies de ça peut être
n'importe quoi que vous allez vous
passer sur le visage donc pour exfolier
tout ça c'est vrai que ça en a besoin et
et ça c'est là elle en fait la pub parce
que c'est en l'occurrence un de ses
produits à elle c'est sa marque Go un
truc du stle donc voilà acheter mes
produitsh je ne suis pas sponsorisé je
ne fais que présenter mes propres
produits je su monorisé par moi-même
voilà voilà génial pourquoi pas euh j'ai
envie de dire mais bon il y aura
peut-être des conséquences àrière
surtout si vous avez la peau un peu
sensible ou un peu fragile donc voilà
évitez d'accord je suis une junky de
l'exfoliation
ok
euh à savoir aussi que les exfoliants ou
les trucs comme ça euh donc il y a des
microbill dedans mais alors c'est pas
juste des microbies en fait dans
beaucoup d'exfoliants euh vous allez
avoir des microbies qui vont être du
plastique donc vous imaginez qu'en plus
c'est c'est pas c'est pas top pour
l'environnement quoi parce que vous
allez rincer ça ça va partir dans les
eaux usées et puis puis il va y avoir
des microbilles de plastique un peu
partout bon bah c'est moyen si vraiment
vous voulez un exfoliant prenez un truc
avec je sais pas des noyaux d'abricot
qui ont été concassés ou un truc comme
ça ça existe euh des trucs un peu plus
ça ça fera le même effet exfoliant c'est
jusequau moins ce sera biodégradable
pour le coup donc ça celui-là je sais
pas ce qu'il a dedans mais je doute que
ce soit vraiment quelque chose de très
bon pour la
planète ah oui puis on gratte bien
[Musique]
voilà on part encore sur un sérum comme
tout à
l'heureil
[Musique]
VO juste quelques gouttes et on applique
le sérum et puis quand même c'est
vachement
bien alors clean et non toxique pour ces
produits là je demande encore à vérifier
ça j'ai pas vérifié mais j'en suis pas
sûr faudra quand même aller voir encore
une fois clean et non toxique ça veut
pas dire naturel il y a des produits
naturels qui sont dangereux pour la
santé renseignez-vous un peu quand
même
[Musique]
d'accord les trucs pour les occasions
spéciales les réunions meeting zoom ah
les pades pour les yeux donc ça c'est
pour les poches sous les yeux on essaie
de mettre des des petits cotons sous les
yeux des petits des petits soins
spéciaux pour les yeux pour essayer de
faire en sorte de pas avoir de CERN
voilà un petit masque pour les yeux
pourquoi pas d'accord donc là on est
parti sur un massage de
de la tête du coup avec un petit outil
vibrant en or c'est important que ce
soit en or absolument bon les vibrations
c'est pas mal pour comme massage
évidemment surtout si vous avez des
problèmes de des fois on a un peu de
tension de machin des trucs ça va
peut-être dénouer les tensions mais je
sais pas à quel point c'est efficace
pour comme ils disent remodeler le
visage je ne sais pas encore quel quel
drôle de trucs il peuvent poser sur sur
la boîte voilà donc je moi très
honnêtement ça ça me semble alors j'ai
pas cherché vraiment ce genre de chose
en particulier mais
géthétiquement parlant je pense que à
mon avis il y a pas d'effet à vous de
voir après après ça peut être un bon
truc pour justement si vous êtes un peu
tendu de la mâchoire sa pas pourquoi pas
mais ne vous attendez pas un effet autre
que ça il y en aura pas et puis on en
applique aussi sous les yeux parce que
pourquoi pas voilà donc ça vibre donc ça
doit faire des chatouilles quand même
et ça on s'en fiche un petit peu
merci alors là on est sur plus ou moins
le seul produit qui va fonctionner dans
tout sol l'au ça va être
effectivement une crème hydratante tout
simplement là il y a rien il y a pas
d'autre truc qui qui est marqué sur la
bouteille comme quoi c'est autre chose
qu'une crème hydratante les crèmes
hydratantes pour le coup ça marche ça va
pas marcher plus de 24 he c'est clair
mais sur le coup ça marche comme crème
hydratante voilà vous allez avoir la
peau un peu plus souple plus plus
agréable peut-être surtout si vous avez
la peau sèche bah encore du coup une
crème hydratante qu'on rajoute dessus
voilà voilà donc là elle fait la la
réclame pour ses produits à elle parce
que voilà quand même il y en avait pas
beaucoup qui étaient dispo et puis il
fallait quand même que je trouve les
bons produits non toxique voilà et clean
et cetera donc bref et là après elle
part sur le maquillage avec du coup son
oui quelle bonne idée et elle part du
coup avec son fond de teint voilà donc
don elle se sert pour pour s serern
uniquement bref donc bon bref vous voyez
l'idée c'est pas la peine d'en faire 15
15 trucs du style vous comprenez un peu
le principe que soit elle que soit les
autres qu'on a vu avant pas tout ce je
voulais faire parce
que sur Youtube vous cliquez routine
makeup vous vous faites morning routine
ou je sais pas n'importe quoi du même
style si on avait il y avait encore
celui-là bah makeup rapide en 5
minutes celui-là est assez horrible
d'ailleurs mais bon après ça c'est à
vous de voir le vous vous vous
mettez je sais pas combien de produits
sur la tronche tous les matins d'une ça
vous prend un temps mais incroyable
est-ce qu'on n pas d'autres choses à
faire le matin plutôt que de faire ça
vraiment vous êtes sûr est-ce queil y a
vraiment des résultats aussi
intéressants que ça je je voudrais pas
dire mais je j'ai pas vraiment constater
de différence entre moi ne pas en
utiliser et les autres personnes qui en
utilisent tuis je au contraire on
m'appelle plus mademoiselle que Madame
souvent donc je vois pas l'intérêt
d'utiliser tous ces produits pour la
peau parce que il fonctionne pas
vraiment en fait et ça va même plus loin
que ça vous avez des produits donc pour
la peau qui peuvent être dangereux parce
que leur composition est pas top mais
vous avez aussi des produits pour la
peau qui peuvent carrément vous faire
vieillir plus rapidement donc j'avais
une page ici par exemple qui du coup est
fait par la skin cancer Foundation donc
la Fondation pour le cancer de la peau
et qui explique que effectivement la
routine beauté peut rendre
photosensible ça ça av été écrit en 2023
tiens c'est juste l'année dernière donc
on va lire deux trois trucs vite fait et
je vais vous expliquer un petit peu si
si l'explique pas suffisamment voà alors
les ingrédients actifs sont les élément
d'un produit qui fonctionne pour offrir
les avantages annoncés lorsque
l'emballage promet qu'un produit lisse
les ridules ré séclat de la peau ou
combat l'acné ce sont les ingrédients
actifs qui rendront le produit efficace
si jamais il le rendent efficace he
parce qu'on est d'accord que la BFF
d'escargot niveau efficacité je suis pas
sûr mais la puissance de ces ingrédients
a parfois un coût comme pour tout
médicament pour ceux qui sont des
médicaments en tout cas hein on n'oublie
pas ce que j'ai dit au début seul ceux
qui sont des médicaments sont
délivrables sur ordonnance ceux qui ne
sont pas délivrables sur ordonnance qui
peuvent être comme ça n'importe comment
c'est pas des médicaments ça veut dire
qu'ils ont pas d'effet pas suffisamment
en tout cas pour que vraiment ce soit
considérer des médicaments donc comme
pour tout médicament des effets
secondaires peuvent subvenir l'un des
effets secondaires les plus courants des
produits de soin de la peau à ind
disdoctane élevé et la
photosensibilité donc la
photosensibilité c'est une sensibilité
cutanée accrue ou une réaction
inhabituelle lorsque votre peau est
exposée à des rayon UV si votre peau est
très sensible au soleil il est plus
facile de subir des donnages cutanées
pouvant entraîner un cancer de la peau
et un vieillissement prématuré de la
peau et du coup c'est quoi le
problème ironiquement ce sont certains
des ingrédients les plus efficaces des
soins de la peau qui peuvent causer les
plus gros mauxs de tête en ce qui
concerne la sensibilité au soleil bah
oui parce qu'évidemment si vous avez un
ingrédient qui est
efficace il y a des effets secondaires
avec malheureusement donc le rétinol
présenté par beaucoup comme le seing
gral d'une peau parfaite peut aider à
encourager la production de collagène
estomper les ridules et uniformiser le
teint malheureusement ça peut également
vous rendre très sensible au dommage
causé par le soleil alors le rétinol
c'est quoi le rétinol c'est plus ou
moins moins l'actif miracle qui va
effectivement avoir un impact sur la
santé de votre peau et sur sur vos rides
et vos ridules donc le rétinol c'est
quoi rétinol c'est ça c'est l'une des
trois formes disponibles de la vitamine
A le rétinol et l'acide rétinoïque fait
partie de la classe des rétinoïdes de
première génération le rétinol est
hydrophobe il peut être synthétisé à
partir de l'isoprène donc le rétinol
c'est une molécule voilà c'est de la
vitamine a en quelque sorte une des
formes de la vitamine A en tout cas et
ce rétinol peut avoir une action dans
les cosmétiques le rétinol est une des
formes de vitamine A utilisé par
industrie cosmétique en stimulant les
défenses naturelles de la peau il aide à
lutter contre son vieillissement le
rétinol est devenu au fil du temps l'un
des produits phar actif contre le
vieillissement cutané il a pu être
stabilisé pour la première fois dans une
crème par les laboratoirees rock en 96
donc c'est assez récent mais voilà c'est
c'est une molécule et c'est la seule qui
effectivement
fonctionne petit bém
évidemment il y a des problèmes avec he
tout n'est pas rose Ce
rétinol si vous avez l'intention d'en
prendre parce que c'est le seul truc qui
plus ou moins fonctionne effectivement
antiâge demandez à votre dermato avant
parce que déjà vous avez des produits
qui contiennent du rétinol mais qui sont
en quantité don la concentration en
rétinol est très insuffisante pour
vraiment avoir un effet permanent à long
terme ou du moins an pour vraiment être
remarqué à long terme sur les rides et
sur sur la peau C ces produits là sont
disponibles directement comme ça vous
pouvez les acheter en pharmacie ou en
grande surface si vous voulez aller sur
un produit qui est un peu plus concentré
en rétinol et qui aura du coup beaucoup
plus d'effet sur votre peau vous allez
devoir passer par un dermato qui va
devoir vous filer une ordonnance voilà
c'est en ça que je dis que ça c'est un
vrai MOC c'est un vrai produit qui
fonctionne le rétinol c'est plus ou
moins le seul truc qui va fonctionner
vraiment attention si vous avez
l'intention euh de
l'utiliser le rétinol euh ça va agresser
votre peau ça va forcer votre peau à
fabriquer de collagène ça va forcer
votre peau à fabriquer de nouvelles
cellules et cetera et du coup à cause de
ça ça va ça va un peu agresser votre
peau ça va la rendre beaucoup plus
sensible au soleil notamment par ça va
synthétiser des nouvelles cellules et
cetera qui eux qui elles vont être très
sensibles aux UV et au soleil mais aussi
ça peut provoquer des rougeurs des des
mangeaisons des boutons enfin bref plein
de choses parce que là ce que vous
faites en vous mettant en vous mettant
du rétinol sur la peau
c'est limite une agression en fait de la
peau vous allez l'agresser pour qu'elle
se défende pour qu'elle produise plus de
ces molécules qui vont permettre un
rajonissement de la peau et donc en
laagraissant bah vous allez évidemment
partir sur des des réactions qui vont
être un peu comme des réactions
allergiques en un peu moins un peu moins
douloureux évidemment donc plus vous
concentrez en rétinol et plus vous avez
des des des produits qui sont concentrés
en rétinol ben plus ces réactions vont
être fortes et plus ça va être
désagréable donc ce que les dermat
conseille et si jamais vous voulez aller
utiliser le rétinol je vous conseille
vraiment d'aller voir un dermato parce
que quand même il pourra vous dire si
pour votre peau ça marche ou pas parce
qu'il y a aussi des contre-indications
comme pour tout
mdoc si vous choisissez d'aller utiliser
du rétinol faites bien gaffe commencez
déjà par des dosages très très faibles
ne l'utiliseer qu'une fois par semaine
ou une fois toutes les de semaines au
début pour que votre peau s'habitue un
petit peu et au fur et à mesure que
votre peau s'habitue vous pourrez
augmenter les quantités mais pas avant
donc c'est pour ça je vous dis
faites-vous aider d'un dermato si vous
voulez vraiment utiliser cette
molécule moi personnellement voilà
j'utiliserai pas mais après chacun son
choix tout le monde est libre mais juste
faites gaffe si vous l'utiliser c'est
pas sans danger non plus
voilà donc ça c'est le rétinol c'est
plus ou moins la seule molécule qui va
vraiment fonctionner de manière durable
sur votre peau mais qui du coup a des
effets secondaires donc le rétinol
présenté par beaucoup comme le cingral
d'une peau parfaite peut aider à
encourager la production de collagène
estomper les ridules uniformiser le
teint malheureusement ça peut également
vous rendre très sensible au dommage
causé par le soleil et oui les
ingrédients qui exfolient donc comme on
a vu tout à l'heure les exfoliants ou
encourageent le renouvellement des
cellules cutanées sont les principaux
responsables de la
photosensibilité déclare la présidente
de la skin cancer Foundation qui est du
coup un docteur lorsque vous enlevez les
cellules mortes de la peau et que vous
exposez la nouvelle peau plus délicate
en dessous hein du coup votre peau
devient plus sensible au dommages causé
par les rayons UV et c'est normal vous
perdez cette couche protectrice qui
était vos cellules mortes et euh et puis
bah tout le le sébum que vous aviez
dessus aussi dans le même ordre d'idée
les acides alpha et betta hydroxylés
donc ah et bha donc c'est les fameux
acides de fruits si vous en si vous vous
intéressez un petit peu à à ces
histoires de de soins cosmétiques qui
peuvent aider à ragénérir la peau les
acides de fruits je suis sûr que vous
vous en AZ entendu parler il y a plein
de traitements maintenant qui sont
disponibles en institut aux acides de
fruits alors là ils expliquent un petit
peu voilà ce sont des exfoliants
chimiques connus pour leur bienfait
antiâge et leur propriété anti-acné ils
peuvent également rendre la peau hyp
sensible les ingrédients éclaircissants
comme l'yrokinon agissent en réduisant
la quantité de mélanine dans la peau
réduisant ainsi les défenses naturelles
de la peau contre les rayons UV donc
hydrokinnone et tous les gent
blanchissant de la peau en quelque sorte
ça va être utilisé contre les taches
brunes que vous pouvez avoir sur la peau
suite au soleil mais du coup ces taches
brunes elles sont là pour une raison
c'est des taches de mélanine qui on sont
là parce que votre peau a été trop
sollicitée par les rayons é et du coup
votre peau a produit plus de mélanine si
maintenant vous voulez retirer ces tch
brunes ben vos cellules ne sont plus
protégées contre les uvé et bah
évidemment vous allez pouvoir avoir
d'autres problèmes de cancer de la peau
et cetera donc faites gaffe aussi à ça
euh et donc les acides de fruits
tous les autres acides d'ailleurs qu'on
va utiliser l'acide glycolique l'acide
salicylique qui sont d'autres acides
qu'on utilise pour faire ce qu'on
appelle des peelings en institut
notamment vous pouvez aussi le faire
chez vous je crois qu'il y a des trucs
pour le faire chez vous enfin bref vous
pouvez acheter des choses qui sont du
coup destiné en fait à vous mettre une
couche d'acide sur le visage
littéralement c'est des acides vous
imaginez vous vous étalez une couche
d'acide sur le visage et vous attendez
donc que cette couche d'acide grignote
les petites cellules de peau mortes et
autres imperfections qui peuvent rester
sur votre visage entre deux exfoliations
n'est-ce
pas et du coup normalement c'est censé
rajunir la peau parce que évidemment en
enlevant cette couche supplémentaire bah
vous allez faire en sorte de un peu
moins voir les rides qui du coup vont
avoir l'air moins profonde et puis vous
allez avoir en dessous une peau qui est
beaucoup plus jeune beaucoup plus
nouvelle parce qu'évidemment c'est une
peau qui n'a pas encore vu le soleil qui
est qui vient de se former qui vient de
se différencier et qui et et qui bah du
coup est beaucoup plus fraîche en
quelque sorte mais évidemment ça ne
durera qu'un temps parce que dès que
votre nouvelle peau va de nouveau être
soumise aux aléas de l'extérieur et ben
elle va retrouver laatteinte que vous
aviez précédemment et et vous aurez
l'air beaucoup moins bah vous aurez une
tête normale en fait en quelque sorte
c'est juste que voilà ça va ça va
revenir à la normale un peu après
donc voilà moi je je conseille pas ce ce
genre de chose non plus j'ai pas
vraiment on reste sur de l'acide he même
si c'est de l'acide qui est très dilué
on reste quand même sur de l'acide
d'ailleurs quand on fait un traitement
aux acides de fruits ou autres on vous
prévient quand même que vous pouvez
ressentir au mieux des picotements au
pire des
démangeaison avoir des rougeurs avoir ce
genre de choses parce qu'effectivement
c'est de l'acide voilà une cellule qui
se divise trop qui se multiplie trop on
appelle ça un
cancer une de cellules qui se diviseent
et qui se multiplie beaucoup trop sans
être contrôlé sans rien c'est un cancer
en l'occurrence ça va être un cancer de
la peau si vous l'avez sur la peau donc
encouragez votre peau à se renouveler
plus que nécessaire c'est c'est le cas
avec ces acides de fruits ou avec les
peelings ou ce que ce que vous voulez
qui qui va forcer votre peau à se
renouveler plus que plus que nécessaire
bah c'est encourager votre peau à former
un cancer en fait et ça vous vous avez
pas envie enfin je je vous le conseille
pas très hnêtement c'est pas une bonne
idée pensez plutôt à la protéger contre
les UV he plutôt avec des crèmes
solaires ou ce genre de chos
mais faites pas de peeling c'est pas
c'est tout ce qui encourage vos cellules
à se diviser plus que nécessaire ce
n'est pas une bonne idée alors ce qu'ils
ont dit ensuite on va quand même essayer
de finir l'article de nombreux produits
contenant ces ingrédients auront une
alerte coup de soleil ou une autre
langue sur l'emballage avertissant que
le produit peut augmenter la sensibilité
au
soleil les crèmes antibiotiques et
antifongiques peuvent également
provoquer une photosensibilité si vous
n'êtes pas sûr des risques de
sensibilité au soleil d'un produit que
vous utilisez pour l'acné le traitement
anti-âge ou les tâches solaires
parlez-en à votre dermatologue encore
une fois allez voir votre médecin donc
votre dermatologue si vous avez des
questions je ne suis pas dermatologue
j'ai juste fait quelques recherches j'ai
lu quelques papiers c'est tout si vous
avez des questions plus poussées si vous
voulez savoir exactement comment vous
vous pouvez faire pour votre type de
peau et comment faire en sorte du
d'incorporer le rétinol ou d'autres
produits un peu spéciaux euh dans vos
soins habituels et ben allez voir un
dermato ce sera encore celui qui sera le
plus à même de de vous répondre pour ce
genre de chos mais ne faites pas ça tout
seul donc assurez que vous protégez
toujours votre peau au soleil afin que
ces efforts ne soient pas vain une
exposition non protégée aux rayons évé
peut annuler tout progs que vous faites
en provoquant des signes de diissement
et de sécheresse une option consiste à
utiliser des produits contenant des
ingrédients qui provoquent une
sensibilité au soleil uniquement la nuit
le rétinol est en fait rendu moins
efficace par la lumière du soleil parce
que du coup bah la vitamine A donc le
rétinol va être dégradée par par la
lumière du soleil aussi donc ça va être
beaucoup moins efficace si vous
l'utilisez donc il est doublement
important d'empêcher les rayons UV
d'atteindre votre peau pendant que vous
l'utilisez la chose la plus importante
est de maintenir une routine de
protection solaire solide peu importe si
ou quand vous utilisez des produits de
soins de la peau qui provoquent une
photosensibilité la protection solaire
est importante tous les jours plus
vigilant quant à l'application d'un
écran solaire si vous utilisez également
un rétinol des acides de fruit des BH ou
de
l'hydrokinon recommande de choisir un
écran solaire à large spectre avec un
FPS de moins 30 alors moi j'ai l'indice
50 enfin bon j'habite en Afrique alors
il y a prescription de plus couvrez-vous
avec des vêtements et compris un chapeau
à large bord et des lunettes de soleil
antiv enfin recherchez l'ombre évitez
les heures de pote entre 10 et 4h voilà
juste faites un peu gaffe si vous
utilisez ce genre de produit surtout les
produits qui effectivement sont
efficaces c'est souvent des produits qui
vous rendent photosensibles et que vous
voulez pas utiliser dans la journée
utiliseer les plus ce soir et n'oubliez
pas votre crème solaire voilà ça c'était
plus ou moins le le brun de l'article
euh je pense ça important je voulais
juste aborder avec vous l'importance en
fait du du maquillage enin parce que
c'est vraiment important non c'est que
c'est pas important spécialement de se
maquiller mais pourquoi est-ce que tant
de femmes jugent que c'est important de
se maquiller parce que selon les études
actuelles on a quand même entre alors
j'avais les chiffres quelque part c'est
entre 40 et 60 % euh en fonction des
régions en fonction des tranches d'âge
en fonction des de de la couche de la
société aussi entre 40 et 60 % des
femmes qui
considèrent que c'est quand même mieux
de se maquiller le matin et qui du coup
se maquille le matin et notamment une
bonne partie de celle-là se sent pas
bien se sent pas confiante en quelque
sorte si elles sortent pas maquillé d'où
ça vient tout ça
bah l'une des réponses c'est évidemment
que il y a une sorte de pression sociale
moi par exemple j'avais sur la chaîne
j'ai eu des commentaires parce que bon
c'est je me maquille pas moi
personnellement je voilà j'ai rien j'ai
pas de fond de teint j'ai j'ai que dalle
absolument
rien c'est pas quelque chose que je fais
et du coup j'ai eu des commentaires de
temps en temps de gens qui me disaient
oui mais non pourquoi tu es pas maquillé
bon déjà ce genre de commentaire
j'aurais pas répondu premier truc que
vous faites de toute façon c'est
supprimer voilà et c'est tout mais mais
ça vous donne une idée de de la pression
en quelque sorte qu'on peut subir quand
on est une femme dans une société
européenne et que on se maquille pas
sans compter qu'évidemment il y a le
regard des autres derrière avec quand
vous êtes ados quand vous êtes jeune
adulte il y a des fois vous avez
beaucoup d'amis qui vont se maquiller et
du coup vous voulez faire pareil vous
intéressez à ça et aussi le le fait de
voir tous ces produits de voir tout tous
ces gens maquillés à la télé dans les
magasine de voir tous ces produits
disponibles des rayons entiers dans les
magasins ou dans les parfois fois dans
les pharmacies aussi de maquillage bah
on se dit que s'il y a autant de gens
qui en mettent c'est que doit y avoir un
besoin c'est normal c'est comme des
vêtements au bout d'un moment on finit
tous par en mettre et puis et puis voilà
donc en fait il y a une certaine
pression de la société de de vouloir
d'encourager les les les femmes à en
mettre alors attention les hommes sont
pas épargnés récemment ça fait ça fait
déjà une dizaine d'années enfin je dis
récemment mais ça fait déjà un peu de
temps que je vois des produits où il y a
marqué for de dessus pour les hommes
avec genre des crèmes hydratantes ça a
commencé comme ça avec des parfums un
peu plus forts comme si c'est vrai nous
on préférait les hommes qui sentent fort
clairement euh mais en tout cas voilà le
les hommes commencent aussi à rentrer
dans dans dans ce jeu des des
cosmétiques euh est-ce que c'est pas
tout simplement l'influence de la télé
du cinéma si ça peut être complètement
l'influence de la télé du cinéma
évidemment euh mais bon il y a la
pression par les les paères aussi
pression sociale et tout ça je pense que
ça joue un grand rôle là-dedans et c'est
vrai que quand on est habitué à se
maquiller tout le temps surtout depuis
l'adolescence elle est mignonne elle a
mis un peu de rouge à lèvres machin
chose bah du coup tu continues dans ta
vie d'adulte aussi voilà c'est tout euh
mais bon volonté inconsciente ou pas
devoir ressembler à ce qu'on voit c'est
ça pression sociale elle est énorme il y
a rien qu'àavoir ces routines minimales
qu'on a vu mais qui dure quand même 20
minutes avec une dizaine de produits
comment ne pas culpabiliser exactement
et puis il y a aussi la question du
est-ce que est-ce que je serais pas en
train de passer à côté de quelque chose
est-ce que finalement je ne fais pas
plus de mal à moi en ne mettant pas ce
fameux sérum à l'acide hyaluronique
parce que quand même visiblement si elle
le met toutes c'est que ça doit vraiment
avoir un effet et puis je veux pas avoir
plein de rid à 30 ans quoi donc on a
aussi ce ce besoin d'être de ressembler
à nos idoles et de se dire bah ouais
mais attends et si je le mets pas
peut-être que bah j'ai qu'une seule peau
quoi je je perds peut-être ma chance si
ça se trouve tu vois et et on se rend
pas compte que il y a le revers de la
médaille c'est-à-dire que si tu le mets
il y a peut-être d'autres conséquences
derrière donc oui peut-être que
possiblement il y a un possible effet
mais cet effet il est pas forcément
positif il peut aussi être négatifin
donc et ça on s'en rend pas trop compte
en fait on se dit oui surtout quand on
est jeune on se dit oui de toute façon
il faut que je préserve ma peau ma santé
machin chose et et on se pose pas la
question est-ce que peut-être c'est plus
dommageable que ça ne fait de bien
à ma peau à à à moi-même à ma santé
elle-même j'ai vu alors ça ça m'a fait
beau ça m'a fait très très peur j'ai vu
sur Youtube et quand je faisais mes
recherches pour ça il y a beaucoup de
vidéos YouTube où en fait c'est des ados
genre 12 15 13 ce genre d'âge là qui
vous parl de leur routine beauté pour
aller à l'école ou au lycée et là tu te
dis oh bon sang déjà à C âge là c'est
terrible et je je veux pas imaginer ce
que ça va donner après en fait pourquoi
est-ce que quand tu as 15 ans tu
éprouves le besoin d'aller te maquiller
bon tu me dis il y a peut-être des
boutons des machins comme ça mais dans
ce cas-là autant aller voir le dermato
ou aller voir quelqu'un pour gérer ses
problèmes hormonaux dans ces cas-là mais
mais va pas mettre du maquillage ou du
fond de teint par-dessus je veux dire
tuas tu as une peau toute fraîche tu as
une peau toute jeune quel besoin y
a-t-il de rajouter un truc dessus tu es
tu es joli naturellement tu vois c'est
pas
voilà ça je je je trouve ça terrifiant
je me rappelle du livre Élise où la
vraie vie de Claire et cherellie raconte
l'histoire d'une ouvrière automobile en
les années 60 et l'idée est de se sentir
en dehors de la misère sociale imposée
par les conditions de travail en usine
de faire semblant de slever socialement
par l'apparence en masquant son
appartenance sociale et ben oui c'est
effectivement un très bon bouquin
d'ailleurs
euh c'est vrai que j' avais pas pensé là
sur le coup en faisant mes recherches
mais tu as raison d'en parler on peut
faire semblant d'appartenir à un autre
monde de rentrer dans dans dans un autre
groupe de personnes effectivement grâce
au maquillage on on peut aussi
l'utiliser juste pour certaines
occasions moi je sais par exemple pour
les mariages pour ce genre de choses tu
sais tu tu mets un petit peu de tu
essaes de camoufler les deux trois
boutons que tu as sur là euh tu mets
peut-être un petit peu de fard à
paupière genre un petit peu de blush
vite fait et puis voilà mais euh du coup
ces occasions semblent encore plus
spéciales parce que bah tu as vraiment
fait un petit effort en plus pour
essayer de paraître un peu plus sympa
euh de faire joli sur la photo de
mariage ou je ne sais quoi tu vois donc
là voilà pourquoi pas mais mais que ça
reste des trucs assez exceptionnels si
tu as vraiment envie de de te maquiller
ou si tu as vraiment envie de paraître
plus joli parce que si tu fais ça tous
les jours au final c'est plus
exceptionnel ça devient juste ta tête
normale donc voilà puis c'est c'est
encore M rien c'est encore un carcan de
plus qu'on se rajoute nous-même en se
disant je dois me maquiller ce matin je
dois faire ma routine beauté je sais pas
vous en avez pas marre d'avoir plein de
trucs à faire déjà pendant la journée
vous voulez encore rajouter une couche
par-dessus tu as suffisamment de choses
obligatoires quoi c'est pas la peine de
de faire ça B je dirais personne nous y
force mais si des fois je connais des
employeurs qui qui forcent les femmes à
se maquiller parce que ils disent que ça
présente mieux notamment dans des des
boulots comme dans la vente par exemple
où j'avais des copines qui alors c'était
pas marqué dans leur contrat de travail
parce que c'est interdit normalement en
France mais l'employeur insistait
fortement pour que la fille se maquille
voilà et donc il y avait un problème de
je risque de perdre mon boulot si je me
maquille
pas dans des pays comme le Japon par
exemple ça peut être mis dans le contrat
de travail en France c'est pas le cas
mais euh dans d'autres pays c'est
possible donc bon on est encore
privilégié de ce côté-là mais mais voilà
ça existe euh c'est c'est c'est encore
un autre niveau euh j'ai envie de dire
de de problématique là bon euh là c'est
même plus un choix c'est une obligation
euh alors j'arrive en cours de route
mais je suis persuadée que tous les
produits sont trop importants pour ce
que le corps supporte ou peut assimiler
sans effets secondaire alors euh il y a
beaucoup de produits qui ont
effectivement euh des trucs qui sont
jugés dangereux euh que soit euh par
l'OMS par l'agence de du médicament par
plein de plein de de de grands
organismes comme ça qui ne conseillent
pas des doses supérieures à un certain
niveau parce que comme dans tout poison
c'est la dose qui fait le poison hein
comme d'habitude alors chaque crème
prise séparément peut effectivement
correspondre aux doses maximal autorisée
euh par personne par journée mais
évidemment quand vous mettez 15 produits
euh sur votre visage et par si les 15
ont le produit en question qu' ne
doivent pas normalement avoir ou pour
lequel il y a une limite stricte dans la
journée bah vous allez la dépasser
alaigrement avec ces 15 produits donc
c'est un peu dangereux faites un peu
gaffe quand même à ce que vous mettez
cela dit la peau est quand même une
grosse barrière et euh comme pour les
moléculle de collagène d'acide
hyaluronique ou de trucs comme ça euh
elle va pas laisser passer les grosses
les très grosses molécules vont pas
vraiment pénétrer plus loin que
l'épiderme donc bon vous avez pas non
plus trop de danger pour certaines
molécules qui voilà qui qui de toute
façon ne rentreront pas à moins vraiment
de manger votre crème je pense
qu'inluence majeur chez les jeunes c'est
plus TikTok et les influenceuses beauté
oui on a beaucoup de problèmes ben on
l'avait vu dans la première vidéo
elle la la fille recommander un produit
parce qu'il était vachement recommandé
sur
TikTok alors TikTok euh pour les
recommandations oui
oui moi perso non je prendrai pas ça
comme recommandation B après euh
j'imagine que chez les chez les plus
jeunes c'est effectivement la la la
recommandation idéale euh moi je vous
conseille pas euh si vous voulez
vraiment savoir si un produit est bon
allez voir les publications
scientifiques euh associées euh allez
vous renseigner regardez les avis des
consommateurs prenez votre petite
application mobile là qui vous permet de
juger si euh le produit est sûr ou pas
parce que parce que ça pour le coup ça
marche tu penses quoi des crèmes
hydratantes alors les crèmes hydratantes
pour le coup ça fonctionne parce que ça
va marcher mais on va on va pas vous
vendre autre chose sur la crème
hydratante sur le flacon de crème
hydratante on va vous dire que ça vous
hydrate pendant 24 he pendant 12h
n'importe et là pour le coup c'est pas
la publicité mensongère parce
qu'effectivement votre peau va être un
peu plus souple va être hydratée mais
bon ça va juste concerner l'épiderme ça
rentrera pas dans le derme ça ira pas
plus loin mais oui effectivement vous
allez avoir une sensation de peau un peu
moins sèche surtout si vous avez
tendance à avoir la peau sèche une crème
hydratante ça peut être une bonne idée
d'en mettre une le soir avant d'aller se
coucher pour essayer de d'avoir un peu
cette cette peau un peu plus souple qui
peut aussi vous préserver des premières
rides en l'occurrence mais là on est
plus sur sur la prévention si vous avez
la peau sèche ou si comme moi vous
habitez dans un climat où vraiment l'air
est très très sec mais encore une fois
ça dépend de vos conditions de vie ça
dépend de de de votre peau ça dépend de
plein de choses donc je peux pas vous
recommander un produit sans vous
connaître en fait et je le ferai pas
aller voir un dermato je pense c'est par
ça une solution de facilité de se
maquiller plutôt que de devoir aller
chez un médecin oui c'est c'est c'est
vrai que ça peut être aussi une une
bonne raison pour ça pour les plus
jeunes après je dirais que c'est c'est
aux parents du coup de gérer ça parce
que c'est des ados tu bien avoir des
parents quelque part c'est c'est à eux
de de s'occuper de leurs enfants et de
gérer ça et de voir si effectivement il
y a un problème si tu dois l'emmener
chez gynéco si voilà sil y a des choses
à faire que les parents savent faire qui
devraient transmettre aux enfants
normalement euh à voir s'ils veulent
transmettre le maquillage à leurs
enfants peut-être c'est
peut-être peut-être des choses à
transmettre dans la famille j'en sais
rien moi ma mère m'a jamais transmis ça
par exemple donc voilà peut-être que on
a toujours été on est toujours resté
très très soft sur la quantité de
produits qu'on se met sur le visage elle
elle était juste adepte de la crème
hydratante et de temps en temps un petit
peu de mascara quand elle sort ou quoi
et puis voilà c'est tout puis la crème
solaire au besoin mais j'imagine qu'il y
a des familles où la maman se maquille
beaucoup et du coup les enfants les
filles vont peut-être vouloir se
maquiller aussi pour faire comme maman
c'est possible aussi comptabiliser 10 15
minutes de maquillage dans le temps de
travail oui et puis il faudra aussi
comptabiliser le le coût des produits de
beauté dans le temps de travail hein
parce que une dizaine alors là il disait
entre 6 et se produits de beauté par par
femme par jour en moyenne c'est une
moyenne hein il y en a qu'on utilise 15
il y en a qu'on utilise un seul voilà
vous imaginez bien que quand vous
utilisez six ou SEP produits de beauté
par jour c'est des produits de beauté
qui ont un coûp donc si jamais
l'employeur décide quand même que vous
devez vous maquiller est-ce qu'il paye
pour ça aussi parce que bon les hommes
on leur demande pas certains font du
tatouage cosmétique effectivement les
ils s'épilent les sourcils et puis après
ils font le le sourcil comme ça ou alors
autour de la bouche ça marche aussi sur
les lèvres pour avoir comme si tu avais
du rouge à lèvres tout perso je passe
trop de temps à être un os des cavanes
ronchon qui sort d'hibernation pour ne
serait-ce que penser à une morning
routine ah voilà c'est terrible ça c'est
terrible mais où va aller l'industrie
pharmace enfin pas l'industrie
pharmaceutique l'industrie cosmétique si
tout le monde était comme ça franchement
ils pourront plus en'en mettre plein les
poches hein c'est terrible vous noterez
quand même moi je trouve ça très amusant
mais on a tendance à parler de Big
Pharma et de donner à l'industrie
pharmaceutique tout plein de théorie du
complot de plein de trucs comme ça
alors que bon au final leur but c'est
quand même de nous soigner pour que ils
puissent effectivement s'en mettre ple
les poches d'une certaine manière mais
mais ils ont quand même notre santé à
cœur derrière parce que si leur
médicament ne fonctionne pas bah ça
fonctionne pas voilà puis il perdent ils
perdent des clients mais pour
l'industrie de la beauté comme ça pour
les les cosmétiques quand est-ce qu'on
quand est-ce qu'on leur applique le même
esprit critique que ce qu'on applique à
Big Pharma parce que on a quand même un
problème là toutes ces publicités
mensongèes tous ces soi-disant produits
miracles farait peut-être leur demander
des compes au bout d'un moment en se
disant ouais non mais attendez euh vous
avez dit que ma peau elle serait plus
jolie au bout de temps de temps j'ai pas
vu de résultat
euh non comme il dit je ne fais que
poser des questions c'est
ça et le fleuron de l'économie française
de luxe et oui j'espère que ça a répondu
à certaines de vos questions s'il y en a
eu et puis si s'il y en a plus B vous me
les poserz en commentaire je vous dis à
la prochaine merci d'avoir suivi ce live
et puis à
[Musique]
bientôt